Berlin it's now home for this activist
in exile the dissident journalists from
Azerbaijan has paid a high price for
refusing to toe the government line
Eamonn Millie's been forced to cut ties
with his family and is no longer welcome
in his home country largely due to the
donor funded news channel he runs online
made on TV is giving fact-checked
information about Azerbaijan about
politics and people needed people need
independent media this spoof video of a
donkey holding a press conference led to
merely being thrown in prison in 2011 it
was meant to poke fun at the sky-high
price the government paid for two German
donkeys but the authorities were not
amused and Millie served 16 months
behind bars at Maidan TV Millie's news
team along with a network of reporters
on the ground work to fact-check the
government's message and investigate
dodgy practices a few takes until they
get their message right media in
Azerbaijan is tightly state-controlled
but from here they can produce stories
that don't pass through government
censors nearly 80% of people in
Azerbaijan have access to the Internet
making social media a very important
platform for activists videos like the
ones being produced here in Berlin will
be broadcast to hundreds of thousands
via Facebook offering an alternative
voice to that of the state-sponsored
media milli and his colleagues say
they're routinely targeted even here in
Berlin he says they've received death
threats we don't enjoy this suffering
but if we don't take this risk we
personally our children and our society
will never have a chance to become free
millie knows that he alone can't change
the future of azerbaijan but he's
determined to give it his best shot
you